first first of all I want to thank you
for coming at you honors I should
declare right off the bat that I'm a
friend of Hanks have been so for some
years I admired him when he before he
took the job I admire him a lot more
after the job he's done a secretary of
the Treasury the name of this book is on
the brink and that's exactly where we
were in September and October of 2008 at
that time our our economy our financial
world went into cardiac arrest and we
had four people in the operating room
that we were very fortunate as a country
to have in place we had we had Hank we
had Ben Bernanke Epton Geithner and we
had sheila bair the head of the FDIC and
I really I know a lot of people in
finance and a lot of people in business
I know people in government and I can't
think of four that would have done a
better job of getting us through that
now it's it's kind of fashionable not to
look back and pick it one little aspect
or another of what was happening then
but our country's financial system froze
up during that period some of you in
this room we're at a party I was at in
September of 2008 when the talk was our
money market fund safe now when you have
three point five or more trillion of
funds held by 30 million people who on a
Sunday night are worrying about whether
they can get their money that that that
money was half of all the deposits held
by US banks at the time you have a panic
you had commercial paper freeze up
entirely and you had some of the biggest
companies in the United States and some
of them are described in this book the
worried about whether they were going to
meet their payrolls in the short period
of time you had the sixth largest bank
in the country in terms of domestic
deposits
Washington Mutual failover weekend you
had the third largest bank Wachovia that
needed a shotgun marriage on a Monday
morning to survive most interestingly
this book starts in early September when
Freddie Mac and Fannie Mae essentially
were broke
here are two institutions the guaranteed
40% or so of all the residential
mortgages in the United States whose
debt was held all over the world in very
significant amounts including by God
foreign governments that would not have
taken kindly to a default Freddie and
Danny you had them honing a very large
portfolio of mortgages themselves and
like I say in early September they both
were broken it's worth noting for those
who who take shots some of the people
who were operating during September and
October that those two institutions
Freddie and Fannie were chartered by
Congress and were ruled by Congress and
for those who have heard them criticize
the leverage in the banking system it
should be also noted that they allowed
Freddie and Fannie to operate with a
forty to one leverage ratio and they let
them guarantee over a hundred times the
amount of capital they had in in
mortgage guarantees so these two
institutions which were vital with the
mortgage market or vital in the very
integrity the United States and which
had received in this complicated Hank's
problem in a very short period before
September the watchdog agency that
Congress had established to watch these
two agencies had given them a clean bill
of health and that clean bill of health
it might be fun to go back and read that
now well let's get on to Hank's book and
ah you know when I when I got this book
I got a little early and and I'm
expected to learn all about the
financial crisis and I did but I didn't
realize that
I'd also learn something about how to
attract women it's a little late I
realize but but I Hank had a had a
surefire a surefire approach which when
he took Wendy out on his first date on
their first date in Boston I would I
would like you to describe it if you
even want to elaborate out a little bit
I like to hear about it let me say
before I do that Warren first of all I'm
just delighted to be here in Omaha if
snow would be just like Washington and
again I've been a longtime friend and
admirer of Warren's and he was a just a
real pillar of strength and a source of
strength for me during the credit crisis
now what Warren was referring to to
something in the book I was not a model
of maturity when I was a a senior at
Dartmouth cup birth date with Wendy we
were at the Boston Pops and she wasn't
very impressed when I made my program
into a paper plane and sailed it at
Arthur Fiedler so but but I did you hit
him no no it didn't but she gave me
another chance but didn't she go home
early that night yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah she went she went home early that
night yeah fortunately he got a second
chance right and Hank it tell us a
little bit about you know Hanks him he
says in the book he says I'm you know
I'm a tough guy that I forget where what
point you said that but he also he was a
wrestler in high school he was all Ivy
at Dartmouth as a tackle and everything
but when the president asked him to
become secretary of the Treasury ah and
Hanks initial reaction was not to do it
but but he decided to do it but he had
one big worry and I think this crowd
might be interested in knowing what
makes a grown man tremble well it was
what Warren is talking about my mom and
I I'm quite close to my mother she's a
strong woman she's very engaged in
interested in politics and policy and
and and she was not an admirer of George
Bush
very unhappy with a war and very
interested in women's issues and so on
and so there have been a fair amount of
speculation in the press that I might go
to Washington and I had turned down the
opportunity a couple of times and I
assured her that I was not going to go
because I had no intent of going and but
then when I had reversed my self and
decided very suddenly it was it was the
right thing to do not to say no to my
country I was in Barrington Illinois
where we where we live and still have
our primary residence and I was there on
Memorial Day weekend because the
president was going to make the
announcement on the Tuesday after my
World a weekend so I was going to see my
mom unfortunately a church we were a
church together I had a longtime friend
asked me about what I was doing next and
I told her of course she went up to my
mom and said isn't this great Marianna
and mom didn't think it was great so
when I when I arrived it did up to tell
my mom she already known about it and
she was and I didn't see her sob that
much but she was sobbing and very angry
but angry and crying and said to me that
I started with Nixon and now I was going
to end up with Bush and I deserved
everything I got and
and then I was jumping on a sinking ship
but I will say I will say this though
and the end I I say that at the time I
finished in Washington my mother had a
different president a different opinion
of George W Bush but but it was a it's
not a good way to start off and Wendy
wasn't much happier with me so Hank one
of the most interesting things I found
in the book and I'd not heard a word
about this before was your account of
how the some top Russian officials had
gone to some top Chinese officials with
the suggestion essentially that they
start dumping the bonds of probably
Freddie and Fannie at that time and and
that almost sounds like a bear raid I
mean I thought that was the sort of
thing that just the evil guys in wall
street did but tell me about that well
it never happened and but were very very
concerned about stabilizing Fannie and
Freddie because as Warren said there was
five point four trillion dollars of
securities that were either insured or
issued directly by these institutions
they are highly levered institutions and
these securities were held I think about
one point seven trillion outside of the
US the biggest portion was inside the US
and we had gone I'd been trying to get
reform legislation from Congress
beginning in 2006 and to get the kinds
of reforms we needed but we are unable
to get action until they were just on
the edge and so we were able to to go to
Congress get the get the authorities and
then is what we needed to really spend
time poring over their books
understanding the financial situation
well I had in the book I recount that I
was in China for the for the Olympics
and their ayat I it was given to
understand
that the Chinese had been approached by
the Russians with with a suggestion that
maybe they they could they could sell to
some of the securities together maybe to
test our resolve who knows who knows why
but that they got one why do you well I
would say that we did it probably to
just I don't know why but we'd had so
many conversations with the Russians the
Chinese and everyone else I just knew
that just the just any kind of a sudden
selling would have really spooked the
markets and I would say it it never
happened but it was a you know and some
people say to me was just about
everything bad that could happen did
happen I say not quite it felt that way
sometimes but we I worried about it you
know the possibility of a sudden decline
in the dollar or or you know other
things that never happened and one of
the biggest concerns I had was getting
Fannie and Freddie stabilized and in a
sense we tell the story of how very
subtly we put them into conservatorship
which was essentially guaranteeing their
debt because it was it was in essence an
implicit obligation by the United States
of America it was sort of like the the
banks had their sins and conduits which
were off balance sheet and with implicit
guarantees well that was a little bit
like what Fannie and Freddie were and we
were racing against time to stabilize
those before we knew some bad earnings
were going to be coming out from the
banking sector and particularly Lehman
Brothers losses so that was a race
against time and I was fortunate we were
fortunate that we were able to get it
done without the markets becoming
spooked or unsettled so that's why I was
you know what why that when I'd heard in
in China got my full attention there's a
front-page story in The Journal this
morning about Freddie and Fannie and
it's very very much worth reading and I
believe it said that there's now a
hundred and eleven billion that's been
put in by the federal government but
that it's expected that much more will
so in effect it it presently looks like
the federal government will lose more
money in Freddie and Fannie than an AIG
by some margin well I look at these
programs for all okay we will get every
penny we put into the banks back and
then with a profit I think right and I
think when you look at all the other
programs we may be surprised to what we
get back and actually even I'm Fetty and
Freddie and Fannie I'm thinking the Fed
will make a lot of money by buying and
holding those securities but you're
right in terms of the losses and to me
the important thing about Freddie and
Fannie is right now the US needs them
playing the role they're playing but one
of the things that got us into this
problem is not just Freddie and Fannie
but if you look at all of our the weight
of all of our programs to stimulate
housing and it just has gone too far
and and Freddie and Fannie are not going
to be able to stay in their present form
and say they need to be I think their
mission needs to be shrunk they need to
be restructured in very very fundamental
ways but right now we need them where
they are but I think how we how we
unwind this situation is going to be
very important when you were getting
grilled by Congress and they would they
would point out how there was too much
leverage in the banking system did you
ever get tempted to say that the
institution that they ran had the most
leverage of all I got tempted to say a
lot of things
but but I resisted that temptation
because one of the things that I am
pleased about was that I was able to
build enough relationships on both sides
of the aisle that Congress did act
before the system collapsed and if it
had collapsed we would have easily had
25 percent unemployment in this country
it would have been a terrible situation
and the crisis that the book is very is
to a large extent the story of the
collision of market forces and political
forces and the crisis came that in many
ways the worst time with an election on
the horizon and so what I needed to do
was to gain action from Congress and
actually what we got on Freddie and
Fannie which was unlimited authorities
I used the word unspecified as I like
it's like it sounded better but we
needed those pass it was but I had to
keep reminding people that I didn't
design this thing and didn't create it
thank you
you had relations with the Chinese long
before this and you used them to good
effect during the crisis that I think
you told me in the China maybe 70 times
or so what would be the American
public's greatest misconception about
the Chinese and the and their economic
system well I do believe there's there's
there's a lot of misconceptions the
Americans have even about our own
economic system you know it is and so
but but I think that the thing that we
all need to keep in mind is we're
operating in a global economy and so
when other important economies don't do
well it hurts us just like when we don't
well do well it hurts others and so the
worst thing that could happen to us and
it could have happened to us during the
crisis would be to have had the chops
economy falter and stopped growing and
looking ahead
the we we need China to keep doing well
we it's in our best interest to have
them keep doing well now there are there
there are plenty of differences and
there differences in the economic area
and in other areas but I think the most
important thing for Americans to
understand is that that there is a
relationship where we're both to a large
extent dependent upon the other
we of course in the u.s. we even up
excuse me I think this can you hear me
okay so in the u.s. we don't save enough
we have a a tendency to save too little
as a people and as a nation we borrow
too much and the it and so we you know
the Chinese savings in capital are very
important to our capital markets now the
Chinese save too much and they need to
continue to open up their economy and
continue to open it up to competition to
move forward with the reform process to
reform their currency to move more
quickly to a market driven currency all
those things and so there's very
important differences and but we just
need to remember that this is a
relationship we need to get right and we
need to work very hard to get it right
and when you you would tell them that in
much more gentle terms
time to time and what sort of response
did you get when you talk to him about
saving more and so on
or spending more well we I would simply
say that that one of the things we
started with under George Bush was a
strategic economic dialogue which is
which is being carried on and what I
generally said see we we agreed on
principle so they agreed open up the
they needed to open up their economy to
the competition needed to continue to
move
the Aram and B which is their currency -
so it was to a greater extent determined
by the market but we agreed in principle
and the philosophy but the it was a
matter of speed and so I would be
thinking they needed to move it this far
in this period of time and they were
thinking needed to move it this far in
this period of time but we but we we we
talked very directly about it and I
think the thing that you need to
remember is that when dealing with the
Chinese or any other sovereign nation we
need to put it in terms of what it means
to china and their people and I was just
totally convinced that to the extent
they sped up the process of reform it
was only going to benefit them and help
them get where they want to get over the
longer term and I would say to them I
believe in free trade and open markets
but you'll make it easier for me to
fight to keep our markets open if you
speed up the process of opening up your
markets but I felt we got very good
results if you look the history and you
look at what happened to the currency
when when I had the dialogue with the
Chinese I think the record will show
that that that it that it moved that we
I was very proud of this ten-year
framework on energy and the environment
because again we are not going to solve
the issues of climate and some of the
environmental issues we have in energy
issues unless you get the two biggest
among the two biggest importers of oil
and the two biggest emitters of carbon
to work together and there's a lot we
can do working together between our two
countries and and again I'm a big
believer in engagement because there's
there's very little you can do
in this world it's important globally
that's done on a unilateral basis you
mentioned President Bush I you know I
I'm a little bit like your mother fact I
want to get to meet her now the she
remember she's changed her mind
no when I get through with this baby
she'll change back but b-but I I did for
the book you know I got more
appreciation for what he did in this
particular situation I begged you know
I've read various economists eloquent
ones you know Adam Smith or David
Ricardo or Keynes and all of that but I
really have never heard a more eloquent
statement that succinctly summed up the
economic world that George Bush made in
September I think of 2008 when he said
in a memorable ten words he said if
money doesn't loosen up this sucker can
go down tell us I mean that really hit
her it was it was it was like the
Gettysburg Address short but to the
point did as I as I read the book I mean
either gained an appreciation for the
fact that he he understood what was
going on and and and he understood what
needed to be done was there ever a time
that you went to him with proposals that
he shot you down on no because he was he
wasn't he was only surprised when I was
surprised when I was surprised more than
once
yeah but but but what was the big
surprise while we get into a well but I
would say that I spoke to him one of the
things I'd learned warmth from my
previous career is no matter what you
negotiate I could have all kinds of
understandings about the relationship we
would have but if I didn't have the
right relationship with the president it
wasn't going to be his fault that was
gonna be my fault and so I had a year
before the crisis to get to know the
president to work with him
and remember he went to business school
he understands he had a good fundamental
understanding of markets and economic
issues he cared about them and so what
the conflict he dealt with was what was
it was the same conflict I dealt whether
anybody who had watched markets we
believe in United States of America that
risk takers should bear the
responsibility for their own losses and
that so big interventions were not
something I didn't go to Washington to
do that he certainly didn't but from day
one he understood that the financial
markets were about our economy and jobs
so repeatedly I'd be coming to him and I
wouldn't have to sell him halfway
through the conversation he would buck
me up and say listen Hank we'll get
through this this we're not always going
to look good these are going to be some
this is going to be politically
unpopular but we're not going to let our
economy go down we're going to do what
it takes to save jobs to save the
economy and that was that was his point
of view and he was you know you talk
about my mother and some sometimes he
was almost like my mother to me he would
be telling me I need to work out need to
get more sleep so in terms of the other
people on the political stage it seemed
to me that going up to the election that
you probably felt that Barack Obama was
both more knowledgeable and more
interested in what was going on in the
financial crisis than John McCain is
that a fair assessment well what I'd say
it's no doubt fair that I had the
conversations I had with John McCain or
just frequent as they were with with
Barack Obama they were more difficult
and I certainly he certainly gave me
more anxiety about all that and
and you know the was now President Obama
was was attentive engaged and I felt
comfortable he was going to support what
we needed to do but I'm quite grateful
to John McCain because and every respect
for him because let me tell you that an
election six weeks away when we went to
Congress and there's no way we would
have in my judgment
got the tarp if John McCain had come out
against it and if he had played the
populist card we would have been left
defenseless and so as I look back I am
increasingly grateful of the way he
handled himself during this period but
during the time he gave you know I lost
a few hours of sleep well Hank yeah you
described it one place in there you've
got something there where you say you
you issued a veiled threat and I read
what you said it's not very fail to me I
mean duplicator well that was that was
when he when he was when he came back
you know there was there is a quite a
scene was when he interrupted his
campaign to come back and I remember I
was testifying at the time and Michelle
Davis who's here with me today it was
sitting behind when I was testifying and
handed me a note and I'm in my blood
sort of ran cold right there and she she
said to me now if someone asks you
excuse me about John McCain coming back
just simply say I welcome the
involvement of you know of everyone in
this and and so I'm because she I think
she was afraid what might come out of my
mouth what we came up here
I see it she talked me on the flight on
the way now but not any of that so but
as it turns out again the it was a
couple days of anxiety but again John
McCain when he was back spent time with
the House Republicans rallying them and
you know and it was so he did his part
and and and then even after we got the
tarp he did not jump on or criticize
some of the things we we had done which
again were very unpopular you know
American people and I'm proud of the
fact that on one level the American
people none of us like bailouts and so
again it was it was you know I looked at
a poll was at some time you know after
the election but after we've done some
of the things we've done and I think
this may be a slightly exaggerated but I
recall that something like 93 percent of
the American people opposed the bailouts
and 60 percent opposed torture and so
that and yet except 7 70 percent 70
percent were worried that we would go
into something much worse than a bad
recession and so we've never been able
to explain to the American people this
wasn't for Wall Street this was this was
for them Hank the you had these
consultations with Obama although I
understand it sort of ended after the
election but leave out the sort apart
yeah yeah the
the both the president and members of
the administration have repeatedly said
during the past year that they really
didn't anticipate the how tough things
would be in the economy but from the
message you were giving them I mean you
expected things that stuff didn't you or
am I wrong on that well or not ask you
sort of which you expected because I I
did not expect them this stuff I
expected them I knew when we went up
there's a scene in the book where we
talk about Ben Bernanke and Chris Cox
and I went up September 18th to meet
with Congress and tell them we're going
to need these authorities and the
difficulty we had at that time was as
Warren said much better than I could the
the arteries of the financial system
were freezing up and so I knew with a
certainty that business was going to
turn down because when you have
companies that it's uncertain whether
they're gonna be able to raise their
short-term funding most CFOs are going
to go to the CEO and say a boss I may
not be able to have all the funding
you'd like for the next 30 days so what
is a prudent company do they start
cutting back but Congress hadn't seen
this yet and so they hadn't seen it yet
in their district so I knew with a
certainty it was going to get worse I'm
not sure I knew it was going to be 10
percent unemployment but I knew it was
it was going to be bad and so then when
the and I knew that if they didn't do
something and it collapsed then the
businesses wouldn't be able to fund
themselves wouldn't be able to pay for
the inventories and and and pay
suppliers and would let employees go and
that would ripple through the economy
and we'd have Armageddon but
but so then when the economy did turn
down we had this terrible situation of
is Congress thought because Congress saw
it the way the American people had seen
it we went up and said give us these
authorities and if you don't we're going
to be in deep doo-doo
you know it's going to be bad well they
gave us the authorities and we were in
deep doo-doo and as Barney Frank said
it's very hard to get credit for
presenting preventing a disaster that
people never never saw or could see did
you really get down on your knees to
plead with Nancy Pelosi I did but but
but you you have to understand that I
was in a Cabinet Room witnessing when
both you know Senator McCain and
Senators Obama were there in the middle
of the campaign with the congressional
leaders where not only did we not come
together it broke out and people didn't
come to physical blows but there were
verbal flaws and it was chaos and then
the Democrats assembled in the Roosevelt
Room and I I went in uninvited and and I
just I did it just to try to break the
you know the tension and to get a smile
or laughter and it and it didn't really
have its desired effect because the
biggest because because I remember it I
as I recount in the book I said I you
know I know please don't go out and blow
this thing up and and the speaker said
to me we're not the ones that are
blowing it up and and she was right
thank you
you know you've got a great investment
background you've seen how government
operate here abroad you know nobody's
had a better
a better perch from which to view the
economy and to make judgments about the
economy going forward and and as I
understand it when you were secretary
you had had to have your money in a
blind trust
and now the blind trust presumably is
over I don't want you to give us the
names of stocks although if you want to
do it you're free to do it I've it just
it but give us an idea of the
composition in terms of bonds stocks
whatever of the portfolio which you've
had a chance to establish here in recent
months well Warren first of all you are
a great investor you do very good very
careful work one of the things I learned
during my career is I'm not a great
investor so I need to I need to find
great investors
I believe the system is the financial
system is stable banking systems in
better shape
I do believe clearly the recovery
process has begun you and I have a
common worry about the fiscal crisis and
this country get to that yeah you have
all the best lines I've ever heard as it
relates to that but it done any of that
so I am you just need to understand also
that what Wendy and I are looking to do
we're going to devote the balance of our
careers to to conservation in the
environment and that's where our money
is going so I am NOT looking to make
more I'd like to keep what I have and so
I'm not looking at it with a really long
term horizon because I continue to
believe with a long term horizon the
best way is to invest in high-quality
companies and in stocks that's that's
what I believe in and if I was a young
person I'd be looking at companies that
have got good
strong market positions for the long
term so I have a lot of what I have is
in fixed income markets and money
markets and eekcast because I am but but
then the others I have tend to be in in
growth equities because I still believe
that the economy can go down and
sideways and whatever but outstanding
well-managed companies and particularly
companies that know how to operate
globally will will prosper over a long
period of time and that's the way you
need a look at investments is over a
period of time I I don't put too much
stake in in quarterly economic data what
happened to the stock market today or
tomorrow I think the right way to look
at it for a younger person is over a
longer period of time I'm interesting
that you said you have a substantial
amount and fixed income does that mean
that you don't worry about a decline in
the value of currency well Warren I
you're certainly not going to to get a
former Treasury secretary talking budget
III just because because I because I
really I really do believe that and I
worked very hard this that a strong
dollars is is is just very much in our
interest in an essential to the success
and the and the preeminence of the
United States of America and I believe
that the best way to have a strong
dollar is again looking at it or a long
term view have a strong economy and to
have fiscal discipline
now the I'm not going to give you a view
is what I think the dot was going to
have with a dollar in the next five or
ten years but which is which is you know
what what I'm really focused on because
I we intend to give away a lot of the
money over you know you know over you
know a relatively short period of time
so if I made you a trustee for my
children and I said you got to buy fixed
income would you prefer tips bonds which
is the Treasury inflation
to type with us or the straight bones
I'd go to you Warren I'll ask you when I
take your advice but I but I would I
would ask myself the question which
really gets back to where you're going
to go which is that again I've which
gets the currency a little bit I have
spent a lot of time outside of this
country and I've spent time on all of
the major economies and believe me every
other major economy China included as
many more really significant challenges
and problems than we do they really do
and we're the richest strongest economy
in the world but we have to deal with a
relatively few very important challenges
and the biggest one is the fiscal crisis
and it's I shouldn't call it a crisis
because it's not a crisis immediately
it's a challenge immediately but one of
the things I learned and one of the
things I write about in this book is
that it's very difficult to get
government to act to get Congress to act
and do anything that's big and difficult
and controversial unless there's an
immediate crisis you know we had an
immediate crisis and we still haven't
got the regulatory reform we need and
again that is is something that's
absolutely critical but so the I have no
doubt that we will deal with this fiscal
challenge at some point in time but the
earlier we deal with it the less costly
it will be the greater our nation will
be the stronger a nation will be and the
less burden the younger generation will
have to bear and so that's hey let's go
back to the fall of 2008 again and that
very fateful week
and the September 12th the 15th you know
at that point really on the Friday where
he wasn't knowing the extent of AI G's
problems even though they were going to
come cascading in a few days but you do
have this big problem with Lehman and
you called together a group of people in
Wall Street and and you thought you had
Barclays signed up and I think they they
wanted to be signed up but they ran into
problems with the British government
subsequently but it seems to me that on
forgetting about Lehman even if you had
Merrill Lynch that it followed a Lehman
bankruptcy I think you and I would agree
that Merrill would have gone almost
instantly right what would have happened
if a B of a hadn't made the deal on
Merrill on that Sunday on that Sunday oh
it would have that they wouldn't have
lasted in my judgment you know wouldn't
have lasted a week what what people miss
and I think it's easy to miss was this
was a doozy
these Christ these excesses have been
building up for a long time
I knew we are overdue for a credit
crisis and I told the president that
when I came to Washington but I didn't
expect anything of this magnitude but
had been building up and had been
building up in the United States and in
Europe and it's as you can see from
reading the papers it's still working
its way through the European system but
have been building up for a long time
and the institution's had been sitting
on losses we had been pressing them to
recognize losses raise capital but so
simultaneously we had on the same
weekend we we learned about the extent
of AIG problems on Saturday we Lehman
the run had already started on Lehman
it was Merrill was going to be right
there so you had those three
institutions and you know as Warren said
we had
Washington Mutual you know shortly
thereafter in Wachovia and then we had
it over the next weeks we had six
European nations have to step in and
recognizing institutions so this was
coming at us pretty quickly from all
sides and is ironic but in effect I
think you talked about Ken Lewis having
an appetite for deals or something of
the sort of there but if in effect he
hadn't made this deal which does not
look like necessarily the greatest deal
he offered a 70% premium on the day when
the probably the next day to stock it
might have been at zero but didn't he in
effect kind of save the system for us
that was a tell you he was a he was a
confident decisive CEO and that that
that there's there's no doubt that that
was very much of a stabilizing
stabilizing action would you you think
we would have gotten to Tuesday on AIG
if there hadn't been action on Merrill
that day why I don't know know what
would happened because I I don't think
Warren I don't think we could have taken
one other big institution build you know
it's just that the system it is I think
that the thing that's hard for people to
understand is you know we have ten
institutions under there that had you
know 50 to 60 percent of the financial
assets in this country and they were so
interconnected ia just it I think we
would have in many ways we were
as bad as this is and it's terrible it's
at this but but we look at what could
have happened to we were pretty
fortunate and Hank
the British had given you that kind of
British like bailed
warning about the situation a couple of
days earlier analysis of Gaia yeah and
but in effect they blocked the barclays
acquisition of Lehman do you think they
understood what the consequences were I
I don't know everything they understood
but remember there was this there was a
a requirement for a shareholder vote
yeah and they didn't but we overcame a
lot of things in this got requirements
that's right and and the but the and
then what we needed was we needed a
buyer that could do what what JPMorgan
did with Bear Stearns which was fill the
capital hole and then guarantee the
trading book during the shareholder vote
because there was no authority to do
this in the US and what I think people
have a hard time understanding because
we're the United States of America and I
had a hard time understanding until I
started over turning over every stone to
see what authorities we have that there
was no authority to guarantee
liabilities or to or to put capital into
institutions but in any event I'm not
sure what but the British were I had
said in the book I had used some some
rarest language when I was disappointed
but as I as I said in a book as I
reflected on it
they obviously had their own issues they
were looking at and the regulator it was
for them a very difficult it must have
been a very difficult decision to let
let one of their banks go ahead and in
the middle of a run on Lehman Brothers
step in and and make that acquisition
and and be confident that they had
a the the wherewithal to do that Hank
Lehman did go down yeah on that Sunday
and Barclays didn't bought a limited
part yeah a much smaller transaction I
think was Tuesday or Wednesday that the
British Authority or I guess the British
authorities said that if you had an
account when Lehman even we're keeping
your securities there you couldn't take
it out you can and I mean they've froze
the accounts basically which I gather
came as a big surprise you certainly
came as a big surprise to me that was I
think that shocked the markets ooh is my
recollection is it was Tuesday but I
could be but the because I recall
learning about it Tuesday and that was
that was actually the day that of the
AIG rescue but what happened was there
the collateral third-party customer and
collateral accounts you know in the
broken dealer and others were frozen for
a while and investors needed to know
that their their accounts were safe and
of course when they weren't with with
with Lehman Brothers in the in the UK
then then then there was a big erosion
of confidence in the in the investment
banking model the viability of the
investment banking model yeah that
wouldn't have happened the United States
I mean you would have had access to your
securities yeah yeah and as I remember
that that was that was it didn't get
publicized much but it was a huge shock
did they consult if they did it wasn't
with me now remember the SEC was the it
was the regulator so the SEC was a
regulator for Lehman Brothers and was
the one that had the lead in preparing
for the bankruptcy as a you know as a
because we knew that was going to be a
possibility and we hope to avoid it and
they were the ones that would have been
talking to the to the various
authorities during that period of time
but it it it sure came as a surprise to
a lot of investors and a surprise to me
thank you and I own and we own it
entirely a huge investment banking and
trading firm and it's our only family
asset we can't sell it and we've got all
these talented people we're making lots
of money you're head of the Compensation
Committee what sort of an arrangement
you have with them could anybody make
twenty five or fifty million a year or
are you going to trade how are you going
to treat these people so that they keep
making money for us but and they don't
leave and go someplace else well I would
say we have to talk about what it is
we're we're doing this and what it is
we're making this to say well let's say
we're doing it today well today Warren
you've got to know that you and I if I
as I say it as I write in the book and I
would have these conversations with
Wendy all the time during benign periods
that I think that the compensation
levels on Wall Street you know you know
all right back okay so I just believe
that just in general during during
benign times and I think you would to
just myself just as this is a journal in
terms of how you and number one and
number two today in light of everything
that's going on and the fact that the
taxpayer came in to and granted that the
reason the taxpayer did what was to
prevent calamity but came in and helped
the whole financial system so not just
the big banks and investment banks but
hedge funds everyone I think that today
restraint is very much in order by the
by the top people and I think the anger
is coming from
hey if you have losses you're supposed
to bear responsibility for those losses
so the way I've talked about it is I've
talked about and said I'd like to see
this anger channeled I'd like to see
Congress feel a you know the pressure
and I know they're working on it very
hard to get the regulatory reform we
need so that you don't need to ever have
taxpayers come in and prop up bailout in
their present form a failing financial
institution we need resolution authority
so any financial institution any type of
financial institution if it's going to
fail it can be liquidated outside of the
bankruptcy process in a way which it
doesn't take the financial system down
and the economy down with that so I
would like to see Congress get that done
and get the systemic risk regulator that
can look at every institution no matter
what the size is and and type and and if
they see risks that are imprudent
restrain them so I'd like to see that
now in terms of longer-term compensation
clearly you need compensation might
might then it should be in equity for
the high paid people that it should be
it should be something that rewards long
term performance it's the only thing
that counts long term performance and
aligns the incentives of the individuals
with the company and its shareholders
are we getting the hook gentlemen we're
done
okay thank you
thank you
you know